Ladies and gentlemen, please welcome John Cho.
(audience cheering)
I'm not kidding, since day one I've been like,
"Can you get John Cho to come on the show?"
How are you?
My pleasure, thank you so much.
Oh my goodness.
But it's true.
Hi, everybody.
I am one of your biggest fans.
This is nuts.
Now I went way back on my research with you.
Uh-oh.
And I cannot even
like handle the fact that you changed the world
when you said a certain line of dialogue in a certain film.
Will you tell me about that?
Oh, yes.
I introduced, and my apologies,
I introduced the word MILF into the vocabulary.
(audience clapping)
No apologies needed.
I was once young, yeah.
You don't age, you look so good.
You just have different hair.
Yeah.
That's all I see.
Did you know you when you said that line
that it would become an iconic catchphrase like forever?
It still is relevant now as it was then.
No idea, in fact, that's not the part I auditioned for.
I was kind of a featured extra in the rest of the movie
and, you know, we did a table read
and I was one of the people who showed up.
And they said, "Can you do these 10 parts," or whatever?
And the director said,
"Would you like to do this other scene?"
And so it all seems really random,
but here we are that sort of,
I guess it launched my career.
But I'm so also excited
to learn that you were a teacher?
Yeah, I had a piece of paper that said
I was an English major when I graduated from college,
and I couldn't get a job waiting tables.
So I saw this ad, and so I taught English Lit for a year
to seventh and 10th graders.
What was that like?
It was very stressful.
It was an honor, it really was.
But I quit that year.
After that year I didn't go back to it,
because it's important to be selfish if you're an actor,
and you can't be selfish if you're a teacher.
You have to live for your class,
and I wasn't prepared to do that at that age.
(upbeat music)